wir lassen heute fünf superm Klassiker
gegen ihre Luxusvarianten antreten so
haben wir z.B Nutella für 3,30 € und
eine Nusscreme für 15 € finden wir
heraus was besser ist außerdem haben wir
noch Currywurst Pizza Pancakes und
chilioncne los geht's mit dem ersten
Klassiker
Nutella das ist Nutella der Klassiker
für 3,30 € und hier haben wir die
luxusvion für 15 €. wir kommen gleich
auf die Unterschiede zu sprechen aber
erstmal öffnen wir dieses frische Glas
Nutella es ist wirklich jedes Mal gleich
es gehört seit Jahren zum Frühstücken
dazu und es geht auch nie auf einmal auf
aber nichtsdestotrotz Nutella ist nicht
wegzudenken finde ich aus so einem
frühstücksrepertoire man hat es immer da
ich habe auch um ehrlich zu sein viele
Jahre nicht so regelmäßig das mal
gegessen aber dann mal irgendwie auf
einem Pancake oder auf einem Brot es ist
einfach lecker allein schon dieser
Geruch so dieses fettig haselnussige es
wird schwer für die Luxusversion und 15
€ fast fünf Mal so viel ist wirklich
krass gucken wir mal auf die Zutat bei
Nutella haben wir Milchpulver Haselnüsse
Palmöl hier drüben das von dem kleinen
italienischen Backshop haben wir zu
Zutaten Zucker Haselnüsse
magamilchpulver Kakaobutter Honig oh
Sonnenblumen lezitin emugato Lecitin
hier Soja lezitin von der Zutatenliste
gar nicht mal so krass unterschiedlich
hier ist kein Palmöl drin sondern hier
ist Kakaobutter drin ansonsten
interessant die zutatenlisse ist echt
relativ ähnlich was hier die
Besonderheit sein soll ist dass alle
Haselnüsse aus dem pamont kommen und
Haselnüsse aus dem pamont ist sowas wie
Pommes in Belgien das ist einfach der
innenbegriff von Haselnüssen genug
geredet probieren wir erstmal die
Geschmacksknospen erinnern an den
Geschmack von Nutella schönes Brot
schneiden wir uns eine Scheibe von
runter und schon mal eine für unsere
Luxusversion gleich also hier riechst
Hal wirklich das eine Nuss nougartceme
das ist eine Nusscreme aber warum heißt
es denn nouurt ist ja auch kein nouurt
drin komisch oder m ja das riecht so ein
bisschen schokoladiger und hier riechst
du halt wirklich brutale Haselnuss also
das ist wirklich das hat so einen
richtig intensiven haselnussguch und
jetzt gehen wir probieren ich glaube ich
habe selten hier gesessen und sowas
einfaches gekocht ich habe einfach Brot
aufgeschnitten und Aufstrich drauf
gestrichen aber wir starten mit Nutella
der Geschmack ich habe ihn schon im Kopf
bevor ich probiert habe dieser Glanz den
die Creme hat nicht umsonst ist das so
ein ikonisches Produkt das sich seit
Jahrzehnten ungebrochen maximaler
Beliebtheit erfreut probieren wir das
Ding ist es ist fast ein bisschen unfair
weil Nutella ist ja so ikonisch dass es
schon ein Begriff für alle nusscremes
geworden ist so wie kannst kannst du mir
mal die Nutella geben dann würde ich dir
das auch übergeben wenn nur das am Tisch
ist so jeder weiß das bei Taschentüchern
wenn du Taschentücher mit Tempo
vergleichst so auch so ja okay das eine
ist halt das Richtige das hier ein Stück
weit an weil das ist Nostalgie das ist
Kindheit das drückt auch immer wieder
die richtigen Knöpfe es ist süß es ist
fettig es ist cremig so der Mund klebt
ein bisschen es ist einfach geil weißt
du was mich interessieren würde schreibt
mal wirklich in die Kommentare wenn ihr
noch nie in eurem Leben Nutella gegessen
habt ob es das überhaupt gibt weil also
ich kenne keinen glaube ich der das noch
nie irgendwo mal gegessen hat K ich auch
nicht Ken niemand der nicht mag und
jetzt wird richtig spannt das tut mir
echt fast ein bisschen leid ne weil es
ist so David gegen Goliat so ein
bisschen aber ich werde euch meine echte
me Meung dazu sagen probieren wir jetzt
die 15 €
Nusscreme boah Alter okay es ist
überraschend auch anders als ich gedacht
hätte also ich habe es noch nie seit be
seit gegessen das Ding ist was mir
gerade auffällt nutella schmeckt nicht
nach Haselnuss sonder nutella schmeckt
nach Nutella so wie ein McDonalds
Cheeseburger auch nicht nach einem
geilen beef Patty schmeckt sondern der
schmeckt nach McDonald's das ist einfach
eine
geschmacksmarke kann man fast sagen und
das hier schmeckt nach Haselnuss und
wenn du es im Vergleich ist dann merkst
du nutella schmeckt gar nicht so sehr
nach Haselnuss sondern das ist wirklich
also diese hochqualitativen hasönüsse
die Konsistenz von Nutella finde ich
sogar noch ein bisschen geiler dieses
cremige weil das klebt noch mehr so im
Mund und ihr kennt das ne Nutellabrot
kann einem schon mal richtig so den Mund
verkleben aber wenn du Haselnuss liebst
dann ist das eher dein deine choice wenn
ich nur noch eins essen könnte ganz
klare Antwort sorry aber das ist einfach
ikonisch ich verstehe den
Preisunterschied eingehend dass das
zweifels ohne das hochqualitativere
Produkt ist weil das hier ist einfach
das hat eine Eigendynamik so ein
bisschen genommen das ist einfach was
Eigenes geworden aber ich muss noch mal
probieren wenn du jetzt beides bewerten
müsstest von ein bis ze m Nutella und
die Haselnusscreme für sich stehend was
würdest du sagen Nutella ich ze sorry
ist so schmeckt einfach geisteskrank die
K ist auch so krass und die andere Creme
15 € das Ding ist ich finde man schmeckt
die 15 € aber man schmeckt die Qualität
aber das acht für mich also trotzdem was
gelernt nutella schmeckt nicht nach
Haselnuss nutella schmeckt nach Nutella
das schmeckt nach Haselnuss ohne Witz
ich vergesse immer wieder wie spannend
diese Videos sind wie viel Lust das auch
macht die selbst zu drehen weil so
Produkte sind ein einfach unfassbar
spannend das war das erste nach so einem
gesunden Frühstück steht mir der Sinn
nach einer knusprigen Pizza weiter
geht's mit Produkt Nummer 2 und hier
haben wir sie wir hatten ja schon mal
eine Pizza bei Luxus VSS klassicaer das
ist diesmal keine Margarita sondern eine
Pizza Diabolo bzw Diavola ich bin sehr
gespannt denn das hier soll wirklich die
absolute Oberklasse der Fertigpizza sein
das ist eine Pizza direkt aus Neapel in
einer napolitanischen Pizzeria gebacken
Schock gefrostet rüber geschickt und wir
tauen Sie jetzt gleich auf und backen
Sie uns hier drüben haben wir eine
Wagner Steinofenpizza mit dr ögar
wahrscheinlich die bekanntesten Pizzen
die du in Deutschland kaufen kannst
gucken wir einfach mal rein der
Kostenunterschied ist auch hier
natürlich gegeben 3,39 € für die Wagner
Pizza und 8,50 € für die napolitanische
Pizza und hier hat man ganz interessant
ihr seht rote Zwiebeln dabei und eben
auch Pepperoni ein interessanter take
aber es ist ja eine Diabolo und das ist
eine diabola deshalb ist der Unterschied
gerechtfertigt was man wunderschön sieht
ist dieses Leopardenmuster am Rand das
kriegst du nur wenn die Pizza wirklich
in ein napolitan Pizzaofen bei 400°
vorgebacken wird dass wir das bei der
anderen industriepizza nicht haben ist
ja eindeutig also ab in den Ofen für 8
Minuten bei 220° und so sehen die beiden
Pizzen nach dem Backen aus einmal 3,39 €
von Wagner Klassiker und 850 aus Neapel
wir müssen nicht über die Optik reden
also das ist wirklich wenn ich selbst so
eine napolitanische Pizza Backe diese
tigerung hinbekomme dann bin ich
wirklich schon sehr sehr zufrieden also
die steht auch ganz schön wir testen
natürlich zu allererst ein mal wieder
den Klassiker die Wagner Diavolo die
schfe wird h scheinbar nicht nur über
die Pepperoni Salami erzeugt sondern
eben auch durch Pepperoni selbst die
steht wie eine ein verneigt sich auf
jeden Fall nicht bei napolitanischer
Pizza Qualitätskriterium die hier tut's
nicht aber es geht wie gesagt eh nur um
den Geschmack und ich habe das Gefühl
dass die sehr knusprig sein könnte
probieren wir auf der Verpackung eben
habe ich schon gesehen da stand was von
knusperrand und so also die Pizza ist
die gleiche wie immer aber die tweaken
die so ein bisschen dass die auch mit
der Zeit geht das ist wirklich nicht
verkehrt die ist besser geworden finde
ich ich habe eigentlich erwartet dass
sie schlechter sein würde ansonsten vom
Teig Teig Tiefe des Geschmacks her und
so weiter ist das wie eine klassische
ist tief Piz einfach ein bisschen
dezenterer Geschmack so von von allem
ausgehend also von jeder Zutat her ist
es einfach ein bisschen weniger
Geschmack wenn das jetzt hier
grundlegend anders ist dann bin ich echt
ziemlich begeistert ich finde was bei
dieser Pizza hier wirklich besonders ist
allein der Geruch ja die riecht wirklich
wie eine frische napolitanische Pizza
und wir leben ja ein bisschen in so
einer großstadtbabel ne also bei uns
gibt's seit Jahren und es gab auch einen
kleinen Hype um diese napolitanische
Pizza aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass
viele Leute einfach keinen Zugang haben
zu sowas und das jetzt per Post zu
bekommen für 850 not bad wenn es
schmeckt let try hier sehen wir die
klassische Verneigung wie wir sie von
der napolitanischen Pizza kennen und
lieben das hat nach so wenig geschmeckt
dass mich das jetzt von den Socken hauen
könnte probieren wir boah also die
Qualität der Zutaten next level wie
diese peeperoni Salami da oben drauf
schmeckt auch der Rand ist außen
knusprig und innen fluffig ja ja das
sehen wir doch ja das Mus se ich finde
dass die Tomatensoße ein bisschen mehr
Salz vertragen könnte bei der Pizza und
ich finde auch dass es nicht ganz an
Pizzeria ran kommmt also wenn du sie
frisch gebacken bekommst da geht durch
diesen Prozess schockfrosten und durch
das Fertigbacken im haushaltsofen geht
schon ein bisschen was verloren wenn du
frische napolitanische h bei 100% ist
dann sind das 80 würde ich sagen okay
probiere die napolitanische aber ich ich
fühle das das Produkt das ist richtig
geil sowas zu Hause liegen zu haben
gerade wenn es halt eben nicht
zugänglich ist in der eigenen Stadt und
so Mama mir das ist wirklich vondon zu
Pasta Poesie auch
irgendere wenn ihr euch selbst von der
Qualität überzeugen wollt das ist keine
bezahlte Kooperation aber ihr kriegt ein
10% Code und wenn ihr da was bestellt
kriege ich was davon volle Transparenz
ich habe ja meine ehrliche Meinung
gesagt falls ihr euch selbst überzeugen
wollt benutzt den Code max 10 dann spart
ihr nämlich 10% ich kann es absolut
empfehlen also ich find es wirklich sehr
sehr krass wenn du dem ganzen jetzt eine
Note geben müsstest einmal Wagner VSS
Neapel 6 von ze 9,5 von 10 no joke ja
hätte ich auch so gesagtine will nicht
ganz ze von ich glaub da geht noch mehr
da geht ein bisschen mehr noch irgendwie
wenn es noch mehr getweakt wird weil das
ist einfach Premium Produkt Schock
gefrostet wenn noch so an der Technik
dahinter feilen würdest dann könntest du
da noch die letzten Punkte rauskratzen
das eine Standard tyfk Pizza sehr
interessant und wirklich diese Salami
die da oben drauf ist unglaublich
gut hier haben wir ein klassisches
chilioncne einfach von der Supermarkt
Eigenmarke das wahrscheinlich jeder
irgendwo in seiner Wohnung in der Ecke
stehen hat nebendran eine Sache an der
ich einfach nicht vorbeilaufen konnte
ein Chili donkne von dem grillshop PAP
hier aus Köln dafür habe ich 9,49 €
gezahlt ich habe das gekauft vor paar
Monaten und dachte mir irgendwann kommt
das in luxusws Klassiker rein heute ist
der Tag wir haben wirklich einen
eindeutigen Preisunterschied hier sind
wie gesagt 9,49 € und hier drüben Beier
doppelte Portion 2,49 € also mama mia
ich muss wirklich sagen das sind 800 g
das sind glaube ich so knapp 350 das
muss wirklich ein gehörigen Unterschied
haben gucken wir mal auf die Zutaten
also Hauptzutat Wasser krass das ist
wirklich krass ne da brauch man sich
auch nicht mehr über das Volumen wundern
so weil wenn die Haup Zutat Wasser ist
dann ist halt die Hauptzutat Wasser rote
Bohnen Tomaten tomatenm Gewürzes
gebratenes Schweinefleisch Zwiebel Mais
Paprika rapsölspeisesalz modifizierte
Stärke Gewürze Zucker Verdickungsmittel
also erstmal Wasser rein und dann
Verdickungsmittel hinterher das ist auf
jeden Fall sehr gut schauen wir mal was
unsere luxusvion hat Rindfleisch 45%
Tomate Trinkwasser Zwiebel Mais
kidneybohen Karotte Knollensellerie
Staudensellerie Paprika Rotwein that's
it Zutatenliste ist hier auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen ansprechender würde ich
sagen also es ist auch nicht mal bis
ganz oben gefüllt wir öffnen das ganze
jetzt einmal zack oh ja da sind aber
auch ordentliche Stückchen drin es sieht
nicht nicht nur appetising aus aber
machen wir es erstmal warm also beides
in Topf geben aber ich meine allein 45%
Rindfleisch ne erklärt auch schon wo der
Preis herkommen muss erste Zutat ja
erste Zutat 45% mit bestem
rindhackfleisch aus eigener Produktion
jetzt der Klassiker chiliikonkanne auß
der Konserve ich habe lange überlegt es
gibt nicht so das chilioncne finde ich
es gibt nicht so wie bei der Pizza
Margerita keine Ahnung wo es dann
irgendwie Wagner oder sonst was gibt
gibt's für mich nicht das eine chilion
carne testen wir einfach gleich also die
Unterschiede sind eindeutig man sieht
wirklich dass hier viel Wasser drin ist
viel Flüssigkeit vor allem auch drin ist
und hier drüben hat man schon fast so
ein bisschen wie eine Bolognese Soße so
eine einreduzierte gekochte Soße will
ich schon sagen ist ja eigentlich
chilion carne wobei das hier eher carne
Conon chili ist umgedreht weil da so ein
großer Anteil von Fleisch dran ist
probieren wir wie immer zuerst den
Klassiker das ist einfach das kennt man
so auch ne und eine Sache ist ganz ganz
wichtig heute entscheidet nicht die
Qualität weil wir müssen nicht darüber
reden dass hier die Qualität mit
Sicherheit besser ist sondern der
Geschmack ihr wisst ja Nutella hat auch
gewonnen obwohl beim anderen die
Qualität besser war deshalb mal schauen
wie dieses Chili concnel mir munden wird
h mal so ein Löffel fertig auf jeden
Fall eine ordentlich Portion 800 g
kannst du gar nichts sagen und für den
Preis ich bitte euch Leute das ist so
ein bisschen find ich wie so ein
typisches deutsches chilioncne was du
bei irgendwelchen Großveranstaltung
kriegst aber die Textur von den Bohnen
und von allem was da drin ist ist
wirklich jenseits von Gut und Böse das
ist einfach nur matschig ist auch nicht
besonders gewürzt und ich finde man
sieht auch auch diese
Verdickungsmittel also das ist ja übelst
viel wasserg ja das ist so das sieht man
einfach wenn man sich ein bisschen damit
beschäftigt ja trotzdem F eine gute
Prise Salz dann gibt mir ein paar schöne
Scheiben Weißbrot dazu ich esse das
irgendwie bei 5° draußen in der Kälte
ist do schon lecker safe hier drüben ein
einfach eine andere Kategorie also finde
aber das wird als eine Portion verkauft
hier ne das ist wenig Bro das ist
wirklich wenig wirst du davon satt weiß
ich nicht kannst nicht beurteilen ist
schon echt nicht viel aber ist ja jetzt
nicht so dass wie wenn du bei einer
Pasta auch eine
kohlenhydrathaltige Beilage hast sondern
das ist nur Fleisch hat eine ordentliche
Säurenote im Geruch ist auch Rotwein
drin ich probiere schmeckt fast ein
bisschen wie Gulasch echt wirklich so
also schmeckt ganz anders für mich ist
das fast so ein bisschen themavfehlung
also der Qualitätsunterschied ist
gigantisch ne aber hier dominiert
wirklich so dieser rotweingeschmack
Paprika dabei Paprika auch dabei
schmeckt man auch stark deshalb gibt mir
auch diesen Gulas Touch was wird du dem
geben von ze und se von ze okay also
oder ist f von ze noch zu gut frage ich
mich gerade ich ge ich gehe fast nie so
tiefer nee vier von ze F vi von ze se
von ze weil ein bisschen eklig ist
es ich bin aber enttäuscht davon muss
ich sagen weil ich dachte das wäre jetzt
so geisteskrank weiter geht es mit
Pancakes und das hier ist wirklich ein
Verrückter Preisunterschied denn hier
haben wir 12,90 € für eine
Fertigmischung und hier 1,99 € diese
Flaschen kennt glaube ich jeder man
füllt sie mit Milch auf schüttelt sie
durch fertig ist ein wirklich ziemlich
guter Pfannkuchenteig und das hier
drüben in ein weggglas schön verpackt
ist auch was fürs Auge aber es muss
verdammt gut sein um diesen
Preisunterschied zu rechtfertigen also
fangen wir an wie gesagt bei Mondamin
öffnen wir einfach und füllen wie gesagt
bis zum Strich hier oben mit Milch auf
das war früher auch schon immer so und
hat mich massiv abgefackt dass die
Scheiße immer unten an diesem Boden
klebt nehmen wir jetzt also unsere
Vermont Blueberry Pancakes Backmischung
oben drauf sind so getrocknete
Blaubeeren was wahrscheinlich auch noch
mal ein bisschen kostet also die
Grundzutaten sind schon hochqualitativer
gehen wir mal rein das ist Hal ein
bisschen dumm ne wenn es da nicht
rauskommt zack einmal durchrühren und ja
das geht tatsächlich in eine gute
Richtung also es bildet sich da sehr
schnell ein schöner Teig auch so ein
fester Teig so ein dicker bisschen
Wasser geen wir noch dazu und dadurch
dass das sprudelt hat man echt das
Gefühl dass es direkt für so ein
bisschen Fluffigkeit sorgt es sieht gut
aus und ich glaube auch dass diese
getrockneten Blaubeeren gar nicht so
schlecht sind jetzt sind die vollen 650
ml drin und es ist schon echt ein
bisschen flüssig geworden ja hen ich
habe mich da jetzt treng an Etikett
gehalten normalerweise würde ich noch
ein bisschen Mehl dazu geben jetzt es
kommt außerdem noch ein Spritzer Zitrone
daran und die pressen wir da hinzu ich
glaube das sind einfach die GOURMET
Pancakes Blaubeere Zitrone ist schon
geil bleibt auf jeden Fall spannend wir
backen jetzt ein paar Pancakes aus und
dann sehen wir uns gleich zum Taste Test
vor mir seht ihr die zwei ausgebackenen
Pancakes und die optischen Unterschiede
sind wirklich eindeutig wir haben hier
einen richtig schönen hohen dicken
Pancake es sind zu eurer Information
sind drei Stück hier und hier drüben
haben wir vier Pancakes die alle etwas
dünner ausgefallen sind und ich finde
man würde erstmal erwarten dass das hier
das teure Produkt ist das sind aber die
günstigen ich finde American Pancakes
müssen eine gewisse Bauhöhe haben die
müssen fluffig sein müssen weich sein
das ist auf dem ersten Blick bei den
hier mehr gegeben als bei denen hier
probieren
wir man kann echt wenig haten daran aber
gut gucken wir mal was man für 12,90 €
kriegt also sind auf jeden Fall eine
Ecke flacher klar du hast deine
Blaubeeren drin in der Verpackung konnte
man ja sehen brauner Zucker ist mit
dabei ist auch ein hochwertiger Artikel
ist ich finde die Konsistenz vom Pancake
nicht so gut ein bisschen trocken ein
bisschen kauintensiver die Blaubeeren
machen viel durch die Blaubeeren
Vergleich zu so einem normalen plain
Pancake bei beiden kein ah und Sirup
kein nichts benutzt sind die Blaubeeren
schon sehr sehr geil das sind aber
getrocknete Blaubeeren natürlich so ein
bisschen wie Rosinen so sehr süß wenn du
dir zu diesem pancakeeteig für 2 3 €
Blaubeeren dazu kaufst und die einfach
kurz reinlegst dann ist das ein
hausvoher Sieg der Pancake an für sich
ist hier besser fluffig saftig und es
ist wieder ganz klar ein haushoh Sieg
für den Klassiker kein buttermilk
Pancake aber sonst verdammt gut 8 von ze
8inhb von ze und hier reiner Geschmack
wenn das inhalb sind 7 von ze aber im
preiskontext ein glasklarer Gewinner
weiter geht's mit dem nächsten Produkt
Curry King ich glaube es gab eine Zeit
von ein paar Jahren wo Curry King
wirklich überall war wo du hingeschaut
hast die haben einfach so krass viel
Werbung gemacht dass das die einzige
fertige Currywurst ist die man im Kopf
hat aber es ist auch eine gute
Currywurst ich glaube jeder kennt den
Geschmack jeder jeder weiß wie das
schmeckt aber was hier drüben habe habe
ich beim Bundesländer Video gekauft denn
das hier soll eine Berliner Currywurst
in Gourmet Qualität sein dafür haben wir
6,95 € gezahlt es sind 235 g und die
Curry King hat 2,69 € gekostet für 220 g
fast das gleiche Gewicht mehr als
doppelt so teuer gucken wir mal wie gut
es wirklich schmecken kann weil die muss
man nicht mal kühlen ich habe bisschen
Angst vor diesem Produkt wir werden
beides im Wasserbad war machen davor
entfernen wir hier noch ganz klassisch
das currypaket und den Peak das ist
schon auch ein geiles Addon ne dass man
das immer dabei hat ist schon cool und
dann gehen wir beides ins Wasserbad
lassen es erhitzen jeweils 10 Minuten
dann ist es fertig sehen wir uns gleich
wieder und hier sind wir jetzt also mit
zwei verschiedenen currybürsten zu einem
ganz schön unterschiedlichen Preispunkt
ist noch ziemlich
heiß kommt direkt aus dem Wasserbad und
hier haben wir sie also ich fülle es
direkt einmal hier hinein sieht so
aufgewärmt gar nicht so verkehrt aus da
steht aber auch drauf mit extra viel
Soße und der Geruch echt kräftig riecht
richtig würzig und kräftig also das ist
wirklich geil und hier Dr drüben haben
wir jetzt den Klassiker Curry King
machen wir einmal auf wenn wir hier ganz
einfache Mathematik machen ne zählen wir
mal was hier drüben an Wurst drin ist
wir haben einfach nur sieben Stückchen
Wurst das hier ist ja 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 also man würde
eigentlich denken dass das das teure ist
wo beim günstigeren Produkt eher dran
gespart wird hier drüben also damit
hätte ich nicht gerechnet dass das dass
das so sein würde was auch noch cool ist
finde ich bei Curry King ist dieses
Spezial Curry Pulver das werden wir
natürlich bei dem hier nicht machen weil
wir testen die Produkte so wie sie sind
und du hast einen größeren Umfang bei
dem günstigeren Produkt das ist schon
krass auch das ist eigentlich wieder
sweet ne dass es so in so einer
pommesbudenschale drin ist und so ist
schon echt ein gut gut gemachtes Produkt
probieren wir einmal rein in der Curry
King
ungefähr so sieht's auch in der Werbung
aus probieren wir es ist wirklich auch
einfach wieder so ein ikonischer
Geschmack der bis von der Wurst die
curryoße was ich aber sagen muss an der
Textur von der Wurst merk man schon
eindeutig dass das eben keine frische
Currywurst ist es ist unweigerlich ein
fertig Produkt das merkt man das
schmeckt man aber es ist schon auch
irgendwie ikonisch und geil das halt das
Ding deshalb lass auch immer Klassiker
antreten gegen die luxusvion weil da ist
ja die Frage so interessant ist das
bedeutend teurere Produkt wirklich
trotzdem auch besser das probieren wir
jetzt mal wir haben ein Stück von dieser
Wurst da steht übrigens drauf weiß nicht
ob das normal ist feine geschnittene
Bockwurst mit typischer Curry
Tomatensoße probieren wir einfach die
Soße bedeckt schon sehr sehr gut die
Wurst ich bin gespannt weil das muss
jetzt wirklich
überzeugen es ist eine Bockwurst ja aber
so Geräuch hat v Charakter ne das ist
also das kann gar nichts der erste bis
die Textur von der Wurst man merkt die
Wurst die verwendet wird ist gut aber
diese Soße sauer bitter alles als erstes
denkt man sich so okay wow geil aber was
danach passiert ganz ganz komisch boah
Leute ihr müsst gerade mal mein Gesicht
sehen komplett
verzogen ist sauer todessauer ja warum
ist das denn so sauer ist noch haltbar
mit Wasser brandweinessig Apfel IG
brandweinessig Apfelessig ja klar daher
kommt die Säure aber das das wird ja
keine Absicht sein dass das so schmeckt
also sorry aber da ist der Sieger ganz
Glas klar und wir waren in Berlin wir
haben eine Berliner curryw gegessen das
ist hat nichts damit zu tun wir haben
das ja in so einem Berlin Shop gekauft
ne vielleicht ist das eine
Touristenfalle aber ey nichtsdestotrotz
wenn man außer Acht lässt dass das so
ein geiler bekannter Geschmack ist W ich
dem sogar eine 7 von ze trotzdem geben
weil es für mich nur an der wurstfront
hapert da ist so viel im agen das ist
eine F von ze aber leistungssieger
definitiv Curry King kann ich nicht
anders sagen es war wieder mal wirklich
deutlich spannender als ich mir immer
vorher vorstellen kann ich denke mir
immer so ja h das wird mein Favorit sein
das gewinnt bestimmt aber es ist kommt
immer anders als gedacht deshalb
schreibt gerne in die Kommentare falls
ihr einen weiteren Teil von Luxus VSS
cllassiker sehen wollt wir haben uns das
überlegt dass wir das auch mal mit
Restaurants machen können das heißt wir
gehen zum mecisen Cheeseburger Essen und
gehen dann einen richtig guten Essen und
so hätten wir dieses Format so ein
bisschen abstrahiert habt ihr darauf
Lust schreibt in die coms wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Video wieder ciao ciao